hello everybody thank you so much for
inviting me miss Iceland the organizers
so you know my name you know that I
built cycle Jess I've also been working
with rxjs and I've been working on our
XJS raise your hand if you've ever heard
of our XJS that's the kind of a good
number so this talk was labeled
JavaScript and we're gonna be talking
about JavaScript but actually most of
the stuff we're gonna see today are like
kauflin haskell java aspectj
and even some Microsoft Excel so it's
like truly polyglot presentation so to
get started there's this buzzword which
is reactive right and we've been talking
about that like a lot of it's kind of
like a cool thing if something is
reacted it's kind of cool but like what
does it actually mean it's kind of
confusing so if you open Wikipedia for
instance you're gonna see automatic
propagation of change or dynamic data
flow I mean what does that even mean
because like data is always flowing from
A to B in any program and it's dynamic
so any program is reactive I don't know
so what do you think and this is
actually a question what do you think is
reactive anyone want to give like my gut
feeling definition yeah okay it's like
an excel you changed something and the
whole thing changes okay that's good I
mean that's good you're getting there
but it's complicated you know it's like
how can you say that a program is not
reactive because well I changed
something and go something changes so I
don't know it's kind of complicated but
what I want with today is that you leave
here to the coffee break knowing what
reactive means and knowing how to
classify that this is not reactive and
especially why do you reactive why is
this stuff important let's talk about
large code bases for a little bit so
they all end up complex a bit like this
so it becomes spaghetti and each of
those boxes is like a class and your
Java code base why can't we just keep it
simple I mean it's it's annoying so the
reason why it becomes complex is there's
two
type of complexities accidental
complexity it's whenever you over
engineer or you have too much stuff and
you need to delete some nonsense and it
basically happens every time you use
Java so real really I mean don't be
offended if you do Java I've been doing
a lot of Java and like for work and for
my master's thesis and it really is
really bad and the other type of
complexity is essential complexity it
basically means that it's already
complex no matter what language you're
going to use and here's an example in
e-commerce you have all of those
concepts and they have to be related to
each other there's nothing you can do to
simplify that it's just going to be like
that and probably there's even more
concepts so imagine that each of these
boxes would be a module depending on
your language it could be a class or a
file or I don't know a module and an
arrow means that you know this will
change that for instance you know the
payment will somehow change the sale and
you know the User Profile will affect
the invoice so if we have let's say an
arrow from the cards to the invoice it
means that you know somehow the cart
will change the invoice as an example
let's say you add a new product to the
cart and then you need to update the
total amount invoiced right now because
you're programming in module so
everything lives inside a module ok
everything lives inside a file or inside
a class so that means that the arrow
also lives inside a module but where
does it live well it can either live in
the arrow tail like that or in the arrow
head so if it lives in the arrow tail it
means that inside the cart module you
have some kind of code that says update
the invoice or basically you know when
you're gonna add a product we're gonna
call invoice update okay so if we look
at a bit of this code in Kotlin which is
similar to Java we have their imports
the invoice Singleton define this other
cart singleton and then we have a method
or a function that when we add a product
product we're going to call invoice
singleton update the invoicing so
so in this situation the cart module is
kind of proactive you know it's
responsible for making that change
happen and the invoice is just sitting
there passively doing nothing and it has
this method there so you can poke it and
save you know update so the invoice is
completely unaware that it has that
dependency with the cart
right it just exposes this method and
anyone can call it so that means that we
need to have the increment counter
public in order for other modules to
change it and we're going to call that
passive programming it's characterized
by remote imperative changes and this
sort of delegation of responsibility
because the invoice is not responsible
for itself but we can define the arrow
in the arrow head like that which means
that the invoice would have some code
that knows how to register a callback in
order to run that function whenever a
product is added on the cart right now
that's different because now the invoice
module will import the cart so before we
have the cart importing the invoice now
we have the opposite and there in the
side the invoice singleton we have this
setup method that will add a callback
there to the cart and then the invoice
knows how to update itself okay so we
put all this logic there so now the
cards assumes this like broadcasting
role the only thing it needs to do is
the cart does its own cart stuff and it
sends out some events about some stuff
that happens inside it and then the
invoice just assumes a reactive role
where it listens to those interesting
events happening in the cart and it
changes itself okay so yeah and for that
we need to make this these events public
on the cart module because then any
other module can listen to those and
voila this is called reactive
programming okay easy definition no
longer a buzz word is that it's whenever
the module being changed is responsible
for defining that change okay it's not
invoice it's not the cart that's
defining
change at all so this is definitely not
new
okay callbacks are reactive there you go
callbacks are cool maybe but you know
next time you argue with your coworker
you can say you know callbacks are
reactive and you can actually define why
so to summarize passive programming is
when you never have remote setting
remote updating and reactive programming
is when you have whenever you have self
updates according to these events and in
both of these cases something needs to
be public so it's not like one of them
completely wins the other they're dual
to each other and it turns out that a
lot of stuff are reactive I said
callbacks but also spreadsheets are
reactive if you don't even check in
Wikipedia they talk about reactive
programming they're just like our friend
above there said that you know it's
something that hates like a spreadsheet
and why is because if you look at a and
B B is basically a times 2 divided by a
hundred and where's that relationship
defined isn't the formula for B ok so
there we go because the the if you think
of in the arrow from A to B that arrow
is defined B that's how it's reactive ok
so back to the real world ecommerce
example let's say you're working with a
system like this and it has 770 classes
or files and you want to understand how
does this one module you know I want to
understand this module ok you usually
have two questions in your mind one of
them is how does this module work and
how does this module what does it affect
in the rest of my system ok so let's
suppose you have passive everywhere this
is usually the case with a naive Java
code base is that every class is
updating the other classes ok if you ask
yourself which other modules does the
invoice change ok no one wants it given
guess but its sale and payment of course
because we have those arrows there and
how did we discover that is by looking
in
side the invoice module then we see okay
it calls sale de update it calls payment
the update but if you ask yourself how
does the invoice module work right how
does it change over time the type of
stuff you need to find all the usages of
its methods you need to you know it just
exposes public methods and you need to
hunt down grip around the codebase how
does the rest of the codebase call these
but now suppose that you have reactive
everywhere okay you're doing like
spreadsheet type of stuff everywhere and
you ask what other modules does the
invoice change then it's the same answer
sale and payment but the way that you
discovered that is by searching for the
usages of those events that the invoice
has okay then invoice omit some events
some other folks listen to those so we
need to search for all of those usages
of events but if you ask yourself how
does the invoice work then you only need
to look inside the invoice module and
then you're going to see ok the invoice
imports the cards and it uses it like
that and it imports the coupon and it
changes its itself according to that so
passive and reactive are dual to each
other in this regard okay in both cases
you have some use case where you need to
find usages some use case where you need
to look inside so can we say that one is
better than the others they look so
balanced you know but the thing is that
you usually want to know first how does
this module work and then once you know
how it works you can answer okay what
are the other things that it affects and
that's why reactive programming matters
and it's a good default because it
allows you to just look at something and
you okay you understand it and that's it
so in contrast if you would use passive
by default okay passive everywhere then
you basically get modules that are
irresponsible because you want to know
how does the invoice work I don't know
you need to start searching for logic
that is scattered all around the
codebase in other models so if you've
ever been in this hell
of like fine usages of this find usages
of that find users of that and then
you're like okay what was I looking in
the first place and you're trying to
build this mental model of how stuff
work you're just visiting the whole
thing that's what I'm talking about
and here's an example that I've done a
couple of times and it was proven really
well to work really well is analytics
how do you set those events up usually
what I've seen is in like a naive case
is that let's say we have a login page
and inside that we have a piece of code
that says analytics dot send event then
the front page says analytics that's in
event and then you want to know okay so
how does analytics work in this
application you don't know you open the
analytics module and the only thing you
see is send event method okay and then
you need to search for everywhere else
that has that but if you do reactive
everywhere then it sort of liberate all
of these pages from knowing anything
about analytics and then if you want to
know how analytics works you just open
the analytics class or file and it's all
there and I've done this for real in
like an Android and Java application
that's been like super nice so and I
really recommend it so right now if this
may be sound sounding like
aspect-oriented programming has anyone
heard of that before yeah it's kind of
like an oldish type of thing it's meant
for cross-cutting concerns like things
that are everywhere like logging or
analytics and here we were able to solve
a cross-cutting concern with reactive
programming I don't want to go too deep
into aspect oriented programming but
here's just a dump example really
quickly let's say you have a login page
and right now has nothing related to
analytics that's good it's only doing
it's logging stuff and with an framework
called aspectj for java you can do stuff
like defining a point cut which is
basically defined moments in the
execution of your program like for
instance the login page was initialized
that's I'm gonna call that opened and
then you can define an advice that is
code to be run whenever
the execution passes those those points
it's basically saying you know after the
execution of the program hits open run
that advice
snip it so with that we're able to
isolate all this analytic stuff in these
advices basically and we can do
something similar with reactive
programming but in this case we need to
add a little bit of stuff which is the
broadcast event so by the end of the
initializing method we need to say ok
broadcast this event called open and so
far there's nothing related to analytics
itself it's just an event that other
modules could use in completely
different ways and then it should be
able to be possible to listen to that
event so for instance here I can make
the analytics class that will import the
login page and then it knows how to set
up a listener - you know whenever open
happens I'm gonna send this event what
do you get is that if you want to know
how this analytics work in my program
you open this class or this file and you
see everything also if you want to turn
off and on the ticks everywhere you can
just remove this class or you can just
swap it with something else that's
really nice right because we separated
the whole analytics concerns in one
place that's nice but if you're a
nitpicker like me then you're seeing
problems and one of the problems is that
I'm not really being honest here because
it's not really reactive everywhere
there's still some passive programming
here for instance back in the e-commerce
example which is basically the same
thing there we have there this remote
update so what is really going on here
because I have a I have a remote update
right the thing is it looks reactive ok
the invoice is reacting to the cart it
is but when you look deeper inside the
invoice it's just the setup phase that's
reacting to the cart but inside that
class I'm still updating some other part
let's say some member of that class
right so how could we not have setup or
updaters at all how could we just use
reactive everywhere and there we go our
friend at the top guess correctly that
something like spreadsheet
there are no update methods in
spreadsheets and that's why you know
business guys love this because the only
thing that they have is data and
formulas so let's stop and admire excel
bit yeah so anyway um and we can model
something like the e-commerce
application because you have there a
cell for the invoice and what what it
does it just has a formula saying you
know I'm gonna sum over the column of
products there we go we don't have any
updates whatsoever here so if we would
plot that as a time line okay then
every time we interact with that column
of products and we add a new product
it's going to add automatically
recalculate the the invoice using the
sum formula and so forth every time
something is added so but what if we
could have more formulas than just sum
and average and all those statistics
stuff that Excel has what if you would
have in Excel like delay if you would
have delay then it means that you know
you change a cell here and after one
second another cell changes here and
with that you suddenly enable animations
in spreadsheets I don't have a demo of
that but just imagine in your mind that
you change a cell there and then
everything's kind of like goes like
funny and stuff well if you would add
not just delay but a ton of other crazy
stuff then you end up with something
like a functional and reactive
programming library like arts Java or
XJS and the idea here is basically to
represent each variable as a stream of
values over time and in rxjs and Java
they call this observables so if this
these would be primitives okay I have a
stream here and I could just pass it
around like I could give it to this
module and then that module would have a
stream it can listen to that stream and
it can do stuff that's the idea you can
just pass around streams as if they
would be like integers or whatever so
whenever I say stream try to put in your
head that it's kind of like a
spreadsheet cell or a spreadsheet column
with superpowers in case you get
confused a bit or you can think of it as
just a stream so how can we get rid of
passive programming here with this
update thingy we can just think you know
every time I add a product to this cart
that's an event right I added a product
so that's an event and if you just put
them all in a timeline that's a stream
of infants and then I could use that
stream of events and I just do a sum
over all of those right kind of like in
spreadsheet and that's what we're gonna
do here so let's imagine that the cart
would have a stream of product added
stream and then it passes we pass we get
that to the invoice and then the invoice
knows okay I'm gonna add over these with
the fold and then we get out a stream of
values of those that invoice total
calculated that's why it's float there
that's really nice because then if you
want to know how does the invoice work
okay you don't need to hunt down any
update invoice method at all even
internally here we don't have any update
at all we can just look inside that get
invoice and we know exactly how this
thing will behave over time just like in
a spreadsheet where you have a formula
there and you don't need to hunt down
any other kind of update method it's
it's not passive anymore
but if you're a nitpicker like me you
probably see a problem anyone see like a
really weird problem okay well maybe
this has been kind of hidden okay yeah
guests are not like updates or centers
so that's not passive but yeah
okay yeah okay uh we're kind of short in
time so we need to go like chop chop
chop so what you're saying is that it's
kind of like a call back still I agree
yeah it's kind of composing callbacks
but the problem that you've haven't seen
is that there's Singleton's everywhere
oh my god what are we doing you know
here we have import the card singleton
and we have defining the singleton
invoice and you know Singleton's are not
good if we do reactive everywhere we get
Singleton's everywhere and if we do
passive everywhere we get irresponsible
modules and you know with Singleton's
you you really don't have reusable code
because it's statically importing some
specific thing and it turns out that
while we were doing reactive everywhere
we missed out on something nice about
passive programming instead it's really
good for data structures whether it's
mutable or immutable
for instance list dot sort is a passive
programming thing because you know the
list is just sitting there waiting and
then you can just kick it say sort and
then it sorts itself yeah and it's also
really good for dependency injection
because you can say yo depend on this
and then it depends on that so yeah and
then when you're dealing with
dependencies there's two things okay
it's like a what is exactly the thing
that I'm depending on and how do I
depend on that we don't need to put
those two things as one we can separate
them so here we had import the singleton
the card singleton and that's exactly
what am i depending on and the how do I
depend on that is here this observable
declaration I'm saying given that stream
of product at is I'm gonna depend on it
like this and this is the bad part we
want to get rid of this so the good part
of passive programming is that the
invoice was unaware of the dependency
right it's a nice thing but the good
thing is the reactive programming is
that the invoice was was responsible for
change in itself so could we have these
two these two things yeah we can with
passively reactive
I'm not joking it's like you can
actually use reactive just to have this
property of how does it work look inside
and passive to know you know I don't
know who I depend on please inject so
let's change this code the way that we
do that is remove these Singleton's
they're not single tons anymore now this
is like a invoice class and then we add
this member their public park cart and
it's public so anyone can set that right
that's passive programming and then I'm
using this dot cards dot product added
observable okay so someone can set that
card for me and I'm gonna depend on it
like that passive style so this is good
because how does the invoice work just
look inside the getter what does it
depend on it's reusable anything but if
you're in it pretty girl like me you
probably notice some problems here this
is not perfect because you know I have
just get invoice inside the invoice
class so can we do better one thing we
can do is we can get this cart member
and put it in the parameter of the
getter like that okay because you know
functions already have a dependency
injection maker mechanism you just miss
the parameter can you just pass that
parameter of the parameter is the
dependency there you go and why do we
have this class I mean go away you know
so in Kotlin you can do this and that's
really good that's why cotton is good
job is bad because in in Java you would
have to have a class doesn't matter so
and do we even need the cart we only
need the product added observable right
and it happens to be on the cart but we
could just make that be the argument so
given the product add an added stream
we're going to depend on it like this
we're going to sum over all the stuff
and we're going to spit out the stream
of invoice values and there we go now we
get a function that only takes an
observable string of product added and
then we get out observe
streamium of calculated invoice
basically this situation here stream
stream stream and the function is a
dependency injection mechanism probably
better than you know setting things like
in class members and because it's a
function we also have the opportunity of
making it appear function and we just
need to make sure we're not doing
side-effects okay what's the problem
with the side-effects here's the problem
if I pass foo to this function I want to
get out a and then I pass through we
want to get eight again I might pass
through again I get B and that's not
nice because you know how can we predict
what this thing is doing so that's why
moving side-effects away gives us this
predictability so we just we can move
these side-effects by putting them in
listeners or observers basically I have
the stream I pass through the stream and
then you can listen to it and do some
nasty stuff like analytics dot send
event and that is a write effect okay
I'm sending stuff to the server that's a
right effect but there are other types
of effects that we need to take care of
one of them is reading write the
opposite of writing for instance every
time the user clicks on buy this product
bye bye bye bye bye that is a click
right and that comes from the user we're
reading that from the external world we
can model that as a stream stream of
clicks and you know if we keep on doing
this we end up with an architecture like
this that has only streams and functions
where all the side effects are pushes to
the extremes where we start with like
read we process stuff and we end up with
writes and on the Left we have pure
logic and on the right we have only
effects and handling and everything on
the left was completely reactive like
spreadsheets and also completely
functional because we don't have side
effects and while out there you go this
is the idea in cycle j/s so yeah and
it's a framework for JavaScript you can
check it out let's look at a little bit
of psycho Jess okay
now you should know everything of
psychologists no no sorry okay yeah so
the way that we do psychologists is that
all the pure logic that I talked about
goes into this main function sources are
basically everything that you can read
from like clicks and sinks are
everything that you're gonna write so
for instance here we can detect clicks
on some kind of button and that is a
stream and then we you know use formulas
like in spreadsheets to make we sum all
of those clicks over time kind of like
you have some in spreadsheets then we
map that to markup okay and this markup
will be the right effect I want to write
this to the DOM and I want to read
clicks from the DOM and this is the
application running in the browser and
on the right we have a dev tool that
visualizes the streams and the functions
between those so at the top we have a
read stream okay clicks are at the top
and at the bottom is the write effects
so basically the bottom square there
encodes the basically the how to make
this markup appear on the DOM and the
vents passing through are this data flow
Network you know it turns out that this
is not a new idea it's basically the
same as an ancient Haskell io model
called stream IO it's also the so called
dataflow paradigm that exists since the
60s or 70s and it's pretty much explored
a lot in visual programming so in some
game engines they use visual programming
with dataflow and stuff like that and
yeah it's it has a lot of connection
with other good sort of existing
literature so to summarize this is what
I want you to take home reactive
programming is self updates self updates
according to events and passive
programming is remote setting why
reactive is because you know you want to
be able to look inside this module and
know how it works right it's a good
default and if you start moving effects
to the edges of your system you
end up with functional programming in
some form and it's a great idea that
brings separation of concerns and
predictable code thank you very much for
listening hi thank you for a very clear
and accessible talk I think you've made
a lot of stuff clear now I noticed that
fans of reactive programming they like
to discuss continuous versus discrete
directive programming and I have to say
I never fully understood it doesn't
matter and if so can you like give the
very short version of what the
distinction is yeah so it really matters
a lot and in this presentation I didn't
try to go into that but a really good
example of that is your age and your
birthdays so your age is continuous
value you always have an age right now
you have an age but you don't have a
birthday right now I mean birthdays are
events that happen annually right but
these two are really interrelated every
year your age changes because of your
birthday so they are like core ideas
that you want to express sometimes some
things are fundamentally events dreams
and something are fun fundamentally
values over time like ages and birthdays
and they happen all over the place in
anything you know is this library using
the ragged effects yes psycho chess is
using react effects and sweet young and
we actually support multiple stream
libraries since Monday and yeah this
Monday so now we have our own stream
library called extreme because I always
wanted to do extreme programming but I
never know knew how to do it yeah it's
yeah reactive X okay thank you Andrew
[Applause]